dans ce centre commercial situé sur la
place rouge
il y a fool pour le début de la campagne
de vaccination de masse contre le coc
u19 comme annoncé il ya quelques jours
par vladimir poutine et sur la base du
volontariat
l'ensemble de la population âgée de plus
de 18 ans peut à partir de ce lundi
recevoir gratuitement le vaccin contre
le coronavirus les russes ont le choix
entre deux stout nick v développé par le
centre de recherche gamaleya de moscou
et puis va corona du centre de virologie
et de biotechnologie vector de
novossibirsk je veux me vacciner parce
que cela me facilitera la ville je
voyage beaucoup je vis entre deux pays
mais j'ai décidé de faire notre vaccin
parce que le vaccin de pfizer ne m'a pas
bien convaincu ma profession n'impose la
vaccination
je suis professeur de français c'est
pourquoi j'attends avec beaucoup
d'espoir l'avenir et notre retour à la
normale c'est pourquoi nous devons nous
faire vacciner
la vaccination de la population russe
allait de spoutnik v avait déjà commencé
début décembre à l'adresse des
populations jugées prioritaires
notamment les personnes âgées le
personnel médical et scolaire dans la
ville de moscou
environ 190 mille personnes ont reçu le
vaccin et plus de cent mille autres sont
en attente selon anastasia racault va
adjointe au maire chargée des questions
de développement social c'est très
pratique les moscovites peuvent aller
faire du shopping et en même temps se
faire vacciner contre le coc u19 sans
perdre de temps
toutes les exigences sanitaires et
épidémiologiques ainsi que les exigences
liées au respect de la chaîne du froid
sont totalement respecté ici
la procédure de vaccination est mené par
le personnel des cliniques de la ville
j'espère que grâce à nos efforts
conjoints nous pourront vacciner le
maximum d'habitants de la ville et ainsi
accélérer la victoire sur l'infection
faux coronavirus
la vice-présidente russe tatiana
golikova a annoncé que plus de deux
millions de doses de vaccin serait rendu
disponible d'ici la fin janvier
au total selon le fonds souverains
russes plus d'un million cinq cent mille
personnes ont déjà été vaccinées en
russie